les femmes ont plus de risques que les hommes
d'être atteintes d'Alzheimer.
La maladie d'Alzheimer est la cause la plus courante
de démence sur Terre,
touchant près de six millions de personnes aux Etats-Unis seulement.
Mais près de deux tiers de ces gens
sont des femmes.
Pour chaque homme souffrant d'Alzheimer,
deux femmes en souffrent.
Pourquoi ?
Est-ce l'âge ?
Est-ce la durée de vie ?
Qu'est-ce que ce pourrait être d'autre ?
Il y a quelques années,
j'ai lancé l'initiative pour le cerveau des femmes
au Weill Medical College à New York
pour répondre à ces questions.
Ce soir, je suis ici avec quelques réponses.
Il s'avère que notre cerveau vieillit différemment
et que la ménopause joue un rôle clé pour les femmes.
La plupart des gens voient le cerveau comme une boîte noire,
isolée du reste du corps.
En réalité, notre cerveau est en interaction constante
avec le reste de notre être.
Peut-être de façon surprenante,
les interactions avec le système reproductif
sont cruciales pour le vieillissement du cerveau chez les femmes.
Nos hormones servent d'intermédiaire dans ces interactions.
Et nous savons que les hormones diffèrent entre les genres.
Les hommes ont plus de testostérone, les femmes ont plus d’œstrogènes.
Mais ce qui compte vraiment ici,
c'est que ces hormones diffèrent dans leur longévité.
La testostérone des hommes ne vient à manquer que plus tard dans la vie,
ce qui est un processus lent et presque sans symptômes, bien sûr.
(Rires)
Les œstrogènes des femmes, d'un autre côté,
commencent à diminuer en milieu de vie, durant la ménopause,
qui est tout sauf sans symptômes.
Nous associons la ménopause avec les ovaires,
mais quand les femmes disent avoir des bouffées de chaleur,
des sueurs nocturnes, des insomnies, des trous de mémoire,
de la dépression, de l'anxiété,
ces symptômes ne partent pas des ovaires.
Ils prennent source dans le cerveau.
Ce sont des symptômes neurologiques.
Nous ne sommes simplement pas habitués à les voir comme tels.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi notre cerveau est-il affecté par la ménopause ?
Pour commencer,
notre cerveau et nos ovaires font partie du système neuroendocrinien.
Faisant partie du système, le cerveau parle aux ovaires
et les ovaires répondent au cerveau
chaque jour de notre vie de femme.
La santé des ovaires est liée à la santé du cerveau.
Et vice versa.
Dans le même temps,
des hormones comme l’œstrogène sont impliquées dans la reproduction,
mais aussi le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Et l’œstrogène en particulier, ou l’estradiol,
est vraiment clé pour la production d'énergie du cerveau.
A l'échelle cellulaire,
l’œstrogène pousse les neurones à brûler du glucose
pour générer de l'énergie.
Si votre œstrogène est élevée,
l'énergie de votre cerveau est élevée.
Cependant, quand votre œstrogène baisse,
vos neurones ralentissent et vieillissent plus vite.
Des études ont montré que ce processus
peut même mener à la formation de plaques amyloïdes,
ou de plaques d'Alzheimer,
qui sont un sceau de la maladie d'Alzheimer.
Ces effets sont plus marqués dans certaines régions du cerveau,
en commençant par l'hypothalamus,
qui est responsable de la régulation de la température corporelle.
Quand l'œstrogène n'active pas correctement l'hypothalamus,
le cerveau ne peut pas réguler correctement la température corporelle.
Ces bouffées de chaleur qu'ont les femmes,
c'est l'hypothalamus.
Puis il y a le tronc cérébral, responsable du sommeil et de l'éveil.
Quand l'œstrogène n'active pas correctement le tronc cérébral,
nous avons du mal à dormir.
Ou c'est l'amygdale,
le centre émotionnel du cerveau, proche de l'hippocampe,
le centre de la mémoire du cerveau.
Quand les niveaux d'œstrogène baissent dans ces régions,
nous pouvons commencer à avoir des sauts d'humeur
et à oublier des choses.
C'est donc, si vous voulez, l'anatomie cérébrale de la ménopause.
Mais laissez-moi vous montrer
ce à quoi peut ressembler un véritable cerveau de femme.
C'est une scintigraphie du cerveau
appelée tomographie par émission de positons, ou TEP.
Cela examine les niveaux d'énergie du cerveau.
Voici ce à quoi vous voulez que votre cerveau ressemble
quand vous avez la quarantaine.
Très beau et lumineux.
Ce cerveau appartient à une femme de 43 ans
lors de sa première scintigraphie, avant la ménopause.
Voici le même cerveau seulement huit ans plus tard,
après la ménopause.
Si nous les mettons côte à côte,
je pense que vous pouvez voir comment le jaune vif
s'est transformé en orange, presque violet.
C'est une chute de 30% des niveaux d'énergie du cerveau.
En général,
cela semble simplement ne pas arriver à un homme du même âge.
Dans nos études avec des centaines de gens,
nous montrons que les hommes quinquagénaires
ont généralement des niveaux d'énergie cérébrale élevés.
Pour les femmes, l'énergie cérébrale est généralement normale avant la ménopause,
mais elle baisse ensuite graduellement durant la transition.
Cela a été constaté indépendamment de l'âge.
Cela n'importait pas si les femmes avaient 40, 50 ou 60 ans.
Ce qui importait le plus était qu'elles étaient ménopausées.
Il nous faut plus de recherche pour le confirmer,
mais il semble que le cerveau des femmes en milieu de vie
est plus sensible au vieillissement hormonal
qu'au vieillissement chronologique.
C'est une information importante,
car tant de femmes peuvent sentir ces changements.
Tant de nos patientes m'ont dit
avoir l'impression de sentir leur esprit leur jouer des tours,
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Je veux vraiment valider cela, car c'est une réalité.
Pour clarifier, si c'est votre cas,
vous n'êtes pas folle.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
C'est important.
Tant de femmes se sont inquiétées d'être en train de perdre la tête.
Mais en vérité, votre cerveau peut être en période de transition,
ou il est en période de transition
et il a besoin de temps et de soutien pour s'adapter.
Si quiconque s'inquiète
que les femmes quinquagénaires aient une performance moindre,
je vais ajouter que nous avons considéré la performance cognitive,
que Dieu nous en garde.
(Rires)
Faisons cela.
Nous avons considéré la performance cognitive
et n'avons trouvé aucune différence entre les hommes et les femmes,
avant et après la ménopause.
D'autres études le confirment.
Nous sommes peut-être fatiguées,
mais nous restons tout aussi vives.
(Rires)
Éliminons ce problème.
Tout cela étant dit,
il y a quelque chose de plus sérieux qui mérite notre attention.
Si vous vous souvenez,
j'ai dit que les baisses d’œstrogène pourraient favoriser
la formation de plaques amyloïdes, ou de plaques d'Alzheimer.
Mais il y a un autre type de scintigraphie cérébrale
qui montre ces plaques.
Nous avons ainsi montré
que les hommes quinquagénaires n'en ont presque pas,
ce qui est super.
Mais pour les femmes,
il y a une augmentation considérable durant la transition vers la ménopause.
Je veux être très claire :
toutes les femmes ne développent pas de plaques
et toutes les femmes ayant des plaques ne développent pas de démence.
Avoir les plaques est un facteur de risque,
ce n'est en aucun cas un diagnostic, surtout pas à ce stade.
Malgré tout, c'est une sacrée information,
l'association d'Alzheimer à la ménopause.
Nous plaçons la ménopause durant la cinquantaine
et Alzheimer durant la vieillesse.
Mais en réalité,
de nombreuses études, y compris mon travail,
ont montré que la maladie d'Alzheimer
débute avec des changements cérébraux négatifs
des années, si ce n'est des décennies, avant les symptômes cliniques.
Pour les femmes,
il semble que ce procédé démarre à la cinquantaine,
durant la ménopause.
Ce qui est une information importante,
car elle nous donne une chronologie pour commencer à chercher ces changements.
En termes de chronologie,
la plupart des femmes sont ménopausées au début de la cinquantaine.
Mais ce peut être plus tôt,
souvent du fait d'interventions médicales.
L'exemple habituel est une hystérectomie et/ou une ovariectomie,
qui est l'ablation chirurgicale de l'utérus et/ou des ovaires.
Malheureusement, il y a des éléments montrant
que d'avoir une ablation de l'utérus et, plus encore, des ovaires
avant la ménopause
est corrélé à une risque plus élevé de démence chez les femmes.
Je sais que c'est une information bouleversante
et certainement déprimante,
mais nous devons en parler,
car la plupart des femmes n'ont pas conscience de cette corrélation
et cela semble être une information qu'il est important d'avoir.
Personne ne suggère que les femmes ne refusent ces procédures
si elles en ont besoin.
Il s'agit de dire que nous avons vraiment besoin de mieux comprendre
ce qui arrive à notre cerveau durant la ménopause,
naturelle ou médicale,
et comment protéger notre cerveau.
Comment faire cela ?
Comment protéger notre cerveau ?
Devrions-nous prendre des hormones ?
C'est une question légitime, c'est une bonne question.
La réponse la plus courte possible actuellement
est qu'un traitement hormonal peut être utile
pour soulager certains de ces symptômes, comme les bouffées de chaleur,
mais qu'il n'est actuellement pas recommandé
pour la prévention de la démence.
Beaucoup d'entre nous travaillent à tester différentes formules,
différentes doses et différents échéanciers,
et espérons-le, tout ce travail mènera à un changement des recommandations
à l'avenir.
Pendant ce temps, il y a d'autres choses que nous pouvons faire aujourd'hui
pour soutenir nos hormones et leurs effets sur le cerveau
qui ne nécessitent pas de médicaments
mais nécessitent de considérer attentivement notre style de vie.
C'est parce que la nourriture consommée,
la quantité d'exercices faite,
la quantité de sommeil obtenue ou pas,
la quantité de stress dans notre vie,
sont des choses qui peuvent influencer nos hormones --
pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
La nourriture, par exemple.
Il existe de nombreux régimes alimentaires
mais les études ont montré que le régime méditerranéen en particulier
est favorable à la santé des femmes.
Les femmes suivant ce régime ont un risque bien plus faible
de déclin cognitif, de dépression,
de maladie cardiaque, d'AVC et de cancer
et elles ont également moins de bouffées de chaleur.
Ce qui est intéressant au sujet de ce régime,
c'est qu'il est riche en aliments contenant des œstrogènes,
sous la forme de phytœstrogènes ou d'œstrogènes issues des plantes
qui agissent comme des œstrogènes doux dans notre corps.
Certains phytœstrogènes ont été associés à un possible risque de cancer,
mais pas ceux dans ce régime, qui sont sans danger.
En particulier des graines de lin,
des graines de sésame, des abricots secs,
des légumes et d'un certain nombre de fruits.
Pour vous donner une bonne nouvelle,
le chocolat noir contient également des phytœstrogènes.
Le régime alimentaire permet d'augmenter les œstrogènes,
mais il est tout aussi importent d'éviter les choses éliminant les œstrogènes,
en particulier le stress.
Le stress peut littéralement vous dérober de vos œstrogènes
et ce car le cortisol, la principale hormone du stress,
est un contrepoids à vos œstrogènes.
Si le cortisol augmente, vos œstrogènes diminuent.
Si le cortisol diminue, vos œstrogènes augmentent à nouveau.
Réduire le stress est très important.
Cela n'est pas que bénéfique pour votre journée,
c'est bénéfique pour votre cerveau.
Voilà quelques choses que nous pouvons faire
pour renforcer notre cerveau
et il y en a d'autres.
Mais l'important,
c'est que changer notre compréhension du cerveau féminin
change notre façon d'en prendre soin
et l'encadrement de la santé des femmes.
Plus il y aura de femmes exigeant cette information,
plus tôt nous pourrons briser les tabous autour de la ménopause
et trouver des solutions qui fonctionnent,
pas que pour la maladie d'Alzheimer,
mais pour l'intégralité de la santé cérébrale des femmes.
La santé cérébrale est la santé des femmes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Oh, merci.